this was jesse smilet with a noose
around his neck on the night he says he
suffered a racist and homophobic attack
nearly three years later he arrived at
court to hear a jury decide that the
attack was a hoax staged by smallet
himself mr smaller what's your hope for
the verdict here guilty of making false
reports to police he could face three
years in prison
brothers abimbola and olobinjo osandero
told the trial they were recruited by
smilet and paid to buy supplies for the
attack
they said he wanted them to rough him up
and shout slurs which made them appear
to be supporters of then-president
donald trump all in front of security
cameras the prosecutor accused smellette
of harming the cause of the real victims
of hate crimes i told the jury
that i thought the evidence was
overwhelming
that in fact mr smallett had faked a
hate crime
and then lied to the police about it
and then
compounded his crimes
by lying to the jury during the course
of this trial and insulting their
intelligence
throughout the trial smilet had
continued to claim that there was no
hoax and that he was the real victim
we remain 100 confidence in our client's
innocence
from the first day of this case his case
has been pre-judged his case has been
tried in the media
and it's unfortunate this is the united
states of america we live in a
constitutional democracy where everyone
is presumed innocent
but obviously if we're being honest that
hasn't been the case
when the hoax was discovered police said
smolette had used the pain and anger of
racism to further his career ultimately
he lost his role in the show empire and
told jurors he'd lost his livelihood as
well
when he's sentenced in the new year he
could also lose his liberty greg milam
sky news los angeles